julio jones is the second in falcon's
history with 60 touchdown catches matt
ryan has thrown 59 of them who threw the
other come on muhammad sanu
i was one of those that's just like all
right it says
it's a new in his throat because you got
a great brain patrino
here here's i didn't even say what the
draft is it's best football movie
coaches chris you're up come on get your
crap together man all right go ahead
jesus
i'm going with denzel washington all
right that's who i'm going with like
you've said remember the titans first
off that's one of my favorite football
movies of all time i think it's up there
but you're talking about building a
culture overcoming adversity
denzel washington was like mike tomlin
in that movie is perfect great motivator
great communicator brings black and
white together and they kick some butt
on the football field love the movie
it's awesome i'm going with denzel
washington i can't remember his name in
the movie off the top of my head but uh
herman boone herman bone but that how
can you even how you shouldn't be
allowed to pick him if you don't know
the name of the character i didn't look
up any of their real names from the
movies i just know what they're we're
calling them in real life what did you
think i did homework for this damn draft
come on zero fun sir that my wife and i
went to see that movie when it came out
our son was two years old and at one
point during one of the football scenes
she turned to me because you're in the
theater and it's loud and yeah she said
alex is never playing football oh great
that ends his career alex right there
all right uh boy a lot of different ways
you can go
and and since it is
in honor of al pacino i'll take tony
d'amato from any given sunday although
i watched that with my son at some point
after we watched sen of a woman and we
look at each other every time he does
something that it ha that that sounds
like something he said instead of a
woman but i'll still go with pacino from
any given sunday yeah i mean he i could
see him being a coach i mean he could
have been that kind of guy for sure and
he's a great yeller that's for sure
scare the hell out of you uh he's got
that mean look in his eye too so that's
with you i'm not a huge fan of any given
sunday though that football movie as a
whole not one of my favorites all right
oliver stone oliver stone did it it
doesn't hold up well some movies hold up
well after 20 years some don't that one
didn't yeah no not my favorite all right
well i'm gonna go with ed o'neal
as my my next pick ed o'neal you know he
is the coach in the little giants which
was you know a funny football movie more
kid-oriented but i mean come on ed
o'neill
if i remember correctly played college
football believe he was a college
running back right uh did all of that i
mean so he's got a great feel for the
game come on he's got a little sense of
humor he knows how to sit on the couch
and put his hands down his pants like al
bundy he's perfect it's a great great
fit he's a real football coach
i saw that movie so long ago that i
don't remember anything about it i do
remember though
fonzie aka henry winkler as coach klein
in that water
the water boy and now you can have a
linebacker wearing that single digit
number it's perfect
you can't do the single bar face mask
like sandler's character bobby boucher
did in that movie but henry winkler as
coach klein in the water boy mama said
mama said mama said mama said alligators
are so ornery because they got all them
teeth and no toothbrush i love that
there's some great lines in that movie
uh that that really is a good one i
thought about him too as going with that
i did uh just for fun henry winkler was
good right then what what happened oh he
pictured the coaches got like a little
birdie and that brought it back his
creativity right and he started drawing
up all these plays and everything like
that look at bobby boucher
um those are those are some mike alstott
plus shoulder pads too oh they
definitely are seriously they look
ridiculous uh really awesome football
movie though that makes me laugh all
right my last one
i'm going goldie hawn that's right i'm
going goldie hawk cats wildcats that is
one of my favorite football movies
goldie hawn takes over for an inner city
football team
and
it's a great movie it's got a bunch of
superstars woody harrelson you know
bubba gumps in it wesley snipes i mean
there's a bunch of people it's really
good and i like it i really do she kind
of brings them
to the championship game they win they
rally behind her it's kind of cool
goldie hawn's my coach of a high school
football team 1986. i remember when that
movie came wildcats in the theater's end
last one for me and i could go a couple
of different ways i was thinking burt
reynolds because paul crew in the
original longest yard he was kind of the
de facto coach right the actual coach in
the remake right but but i got to go i
got to go this is one we talked about
not that long ago i got to go craig t
nelson not as coach
but as serious but as nickerson i know i
thought all the right moves yeah black
bald stefan georgeovich because
georgiovich trashed his house and he he
told all those colleges he's a problem
he's a problem and finally i don't want
to spoil it if you've had come on it's
been 40 years if they haven't seen it
with you reverses the black ball and
helps georgeovich uh get to college
actually takes him with him when
when craig t nelson's character becomes
a college uh assistant coach well why
always had a putter always had a it was
either a putter or a nine iron why
didn't that would be a dangerous thing
for a coach to have yes at a football
practice why did he trash his house i
can't remember it's been a while like
what was it they were mad they lost
somebody take him out i can't remember
they had lost a big game
and uh called a bad play at the end
should have taken a knee fumbled the
ball denucci fumbled i think and and uh
and then georgiovich got got kicked off
the team
after the game so they all got drunk at
the bar and they decided to go trash
this house yeah georgeovich was there
and they all took off and he didn't get
in the car and he saw him so i i
remember way too much about it yeah
apparently you do you've seen this too
many times who's your least favorite
movie type football coach like the guy
that can't pull it off uh uh dennis
leary in draft day just because i hate
everything about him
i knew you were gonna go back to that
larry i got nothing against dennis larry
movie about wasted two days of your life
everything about it they wasted two days
of my life and the movie is horrible
sorry nfl the movie's horrible the
plot's not believable i could go on and
on
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports